the Irish see brexit negotiation
redlines cut right through it
into the northern island port of land
leaving the European Union could be
complicating things on this ancient
trading route from Scotland into here if
everyone remains committed to avoiding
any form of land border on this island
and brexit means leaving the single
market and customs union this is where
this week's frantic negotiations may
lead to some form of regulatory border
here on the Irish Sea this is the
livestock inspection facility at the
port of Larne in Northern Ireland first
a surprise to many there are already
checks on the trade in animals and
animal products into Northern Ireland
even from Scotland sheep and cattle may
be offloaded into here in order for us
to be able to do inspections and check
some of the consignments of life start
coming in when the second ferry of the
day arrives with a lorry load of
Scottish cattle out to come the
inspectors and the paperwork
extraordinarily the Irish backstop and
therefore the brexit deal rests on Daisy
and friends imported here to learn from
elsewhere in Great Britain yet subject
to checks from inspectors and vets this
is a precedent say the European Union
for further such jerks
indeed this was the point made in the
latest speech of the EU chief negotiator
Michel Barnier
such checks already exist in the port of
LAN and Belfast in Northern Ireland
however they would have to cover 100
procent rather than 10% of live animals
and animals derived products which would
involve a significant change in term of
scale never says the local MP Sammy
Wilson who happens to be the brexit
spokesman of the DUP the party keeping
the prime minister in office his party
disappointed by their talks in Brussels
and a feeling Tereza Mays government
will compromise
he is willing to vote down any deal with
a backstop vote down the budgets and
more we have not said that we would what
we want to vote the government right we
have simply said we want to pull the
government back into keeping its
promises to maybe a different leader so
it may lead to a different leader that's
not a question for us we're not members
of the Conservative Party I thought the
conservative party of the side is there
somebody else who could he lose wounds a
deal maybe in reached between London and
Brussels but from this port town with
the DUP s power over number 10 the
possibility of Irish sea border checks
and the EU insistence that they already
exists these waters look far trickier to
navigate Faisal Islam Sky News in lon
Northern Ireland